why are you so obsessed with studying
the ci and the fbi
well i'll tell you uh when i was a
younger reporter
way back in the 20th century uh i became
very interested
in what was going on in the reagan
administration
they were selling weapons
to the iranian revolutionary guard
skimming the prophets
and giving them to the anti-communist
guerrillas in central america
and people got in a lot of trouble for
that including the president of the
united states
so i wanted to know how did the secret
operations of the government work
the biggest secret operation of the time
1987 was the cia was sending
hundreds of millions of dollars of
weapons to the afghan mujahideen the
holy warriors
in afghanistan who were fighting the
soviet army
but occupied afghanistan at the end of
1979.
so reporters didn't go to afghanistan
not with the mujahideen
maybe they'd fly in with the red army in
the kabul
uh but they didn't go into the side of
the afghan rebels
i said well i'm young i wasn't married
then
didn't have any kids then i said i'm
gonna do that
so before i went off to afghanistan i
called up the cia
that was running this huge covert
operation so huge that
you know it was hard to conceal it was
like trying to hide an
elephant with a handkerchief so uh i
called up the public
information officer at the cia that is a
guy there is
a public information officer at our most
secret intelligence agency the cia
and i said hey uh i'm going off to
afghanistan and you guys
often do country briefings where
journalists are going up to strange
countries
how about a briefing on afghanistan and
he told me to stick it where the sun
don't shine
so off i went to afghanistan
why would they want to talk about a
secret operation right
so i went to afghanistan for three
months
i saw a stinger missile fired at a mig
soviet mig i saw the brave mujahideen
fighting the red army
i saw him fight and die and i came back
to washington
and i hadn't been back at my desk for
more than a day and the phone rang
guess who same person that's a guy from
the ci and now he's really friendly hey
tim
how you doing how do you like to come in
for that briefing now
so i walk in i get invited to see i
headquarters
seven miles up the potomac river from
washington
out in the woods and i go through
checkpoint one checkpoint two checkpoint
three
into the headquarters of the ci and i
look up
on the left-hand wall and they're
inscribed in really big gold letters
from the gospel of john it says and ye
shall know the truth
and the truth will make you free well
i'm hooked at that point
i decided that i was going to cover the
cia like other reporters
covering the cops or the courts
and that's what i've done for most of
the rest of my life since then tim let
me ask you did they ever
try to recruit you they did see i ever
say well if
a guy like this you have the courage to
go out there and do this what if we come
recruit you
no you know that's a nice fantasy but no
that never happened that way
you know people don't really understand
what the ci
is what the cia does they think it's
either
you know james bond flies into a foreign
capital makes love to a beautiful woman
has two martinis overthrows the
government leaves on the midnight plane
yeah that's really not the way it works
um it's a dirty difficult dangerous
business and people get burned and
sometimes lives are at stake sometimes
the fate of nations is at stake
you know from your own personal history
your family history
that the cia decided it would be a good
idea to overthrow
the freely elected leader of iran in
and put the shah on the peacock throne
the shah was a great friend of the
united states
bought hundreds of millions of dollars
billions of dollars of our weapons
uh but the consequence of that 25 years
later
was the rise of the ayatollahs and the
fall of the shot
and here we are today 40 years later so
the folly in the glory my new book which
is about america
russia and political warfare
from 1945 to 2020.
people think the cold war was one thing
and the cold war has been over for 30
years and now it's now but no
there is a through line from the end of
world war
ii to this present moment and these two
nations america and russia
have been at war with each other but
it's political warfare
it's the way you go to war
without nuclear weapons smart bombs
or sending in the marines we couldn't go
to war that way
because if we did our nations would be
reduced to smoking radiating ruins in a
matter of two hours
so we had to go to war with espionage
sabotage subversion secret operations
and that struggle never ended it didn't
end when the cold war was over
you can see it right now today because
vladimir putin
is running a multitude of covert
operations trying to damage our
democracy
pick up paper turn on the news see it
happening every day
he ran probably the most brilliant
covert operation
since the trojan horse back in the last
election
rubbing salt in our wounds deepening our
divisions
this information propaganda fake news
and he's doing it again right now the
difference is
he's got the president of the united
states how are they doing the same thing
and our intelligence services are on red
alert
because if putin succeeds it could be
the death of american democracy
that is what this book is ultimately
[Music]
about